(dreamy dance music)
- [Narrator] Rising
out of the Tuscan hills
are some colorful and unusual figures
inspired by tarot cards.
The Tarot Park is located in Tuscany,
a few hours outside of Rome.
The park took 20 years to complete
and includes 22 figures
from the tarot deck.
There's a Sphynx that
leads to a golden skeleton
riding a blue horse over a green sea.
This represents death.
The hanged man can be found inside one
of the sparkling grottos,
suspended from the ceiling.
And one of the most bizarre figures
is the Oracle, which
is a hollow-eyed figure
surrounded and covered by snakes.
The eccentric artist
who created this garden
was Niki de Saint Phalle.
In the early 1950s, Niki
was committed to an asylum
and believes it was art
that eventually healed her.
She wanted to create a
place that would have
the same healing effect
on those who visited.
The park opened in 1998,
just four years before Niki's death.
In her own words, she
dreamt of building a garden
that would be dialog between
sculpture and nature-
a place to dream in.
(sonic beeping)